oh that hurts a lot oh oh
my God
back in 2011 just before the start of
this podcast a hugely influential book
was released that greatly inspired me
both as a writer and as an athlete and
made the entire Running World seem to
stop and pay attention that book of
course was called Born to Run at the
time I wrote Born to Run the running
bookshelf was pretty thin it was ultra
marathon man which was a great adventure
and then a bunch of stuff about how not
to get chafed over a decade later I
finally had the honor and the privilege
to sit down with the author of that Mega
bestseller Christopher McDougall as well
as the co-author of its sequel Eric
Orton Yes you heard me right Born to Run
2 is here I think too many of us start
to stray into the world of exercise as
punishments as a test of our inner worth
but exercise is a sense of like
joyfulness of creativity of artistry
along with race ready recipes and shoe
recommendations Born to Run 2 focuses on
training regimens to help get you in
shape corrective drills to perfect your
form as well as tons of great advice on
how to add more joy to your running and
how to find a local running Community I
think people misunderstand that focusing
on form is tedious to me it's really
joyful don't view starting running
as a workout create the joy first
and everything else they follow in
addition to being the Born to Run 2
co-author Eric is also Christopher's
running coach and before he left the
podcast Studio Eric actually ran knee
through a handful of drills and PT
positions to help me work through my
chronic back pain and I have to say it
helped me tremendously
in any event it is now my great pleasure
to present you with this conversation
between me Christopher McDougall and
Eric Orton
well welcome gentlemen I'm so excited to
talk to both of you today this is a real
treat for me personally and I think it's
going to be for the audience and my
intention going into this is twofold on
the one hand obviously we have
Christopher McDougall here I want to
hear all his amazing stories from his
journeys emanating from Born to Run a
book that you know we all fell in love
with several years ago and then also to
have it be kind of part tutorial
practical tools for running and lifelong
pain-free Fitness with you Eric so I
think together we're going to create a
really cool unique experience and to
kick it off I mean I just have to say
you know Christopher like I just I I you
know my heart is bursting wide open just
to meet you like your book and the work
that you've done has been such a huge
influence on me both as an athlete and
and as a writer so this is long overdue
I know we've been trying to make this
happen for a long time so I'm just super
excited to meet both of you you guys and
be able to do this that is really super
heartwarming thank you thank you I
remember
when born to one born came out it came
out in March of 2011 right originally
2009 2009. actually rich can I even
interrupt yourself we brought you a
little gift this is a hand woven thought
romater running bracelet oh wow and uh
Eric and I are both wearing them brought
you one just because you know it's a
little ritual that that do before they
do like a multi-day event we're on the
same team we're gonna you know it's like
if you feel pretty you run pretty yeah
so I just want to get all right man
thanks buddy I appreciate that they're
sliding it on right now right this was
this made by yeah yeah that's right
unclear on how to exactly pronounce that
we have a friend who has a contact in
one of the villages and will you know
buy these hand bracelets and we sort of
like to have them
I had one experience running with uh
with a Tata motto I did a running event
for runners World magazine in Mexico
City several years ago and one of the
guys came up and I was able it was at a
track like at a university but I was
able to kind of run right behind tuck in
right behind him and run behind him on
on a track and I've never seen anything
like it that's smart the the uh
it's one thing to talk about their form
and how free they are when they're
running but to actually experience that
close up and to really see how
effortless it is and how joyful it is I
mean this guy looked like he was walking
and he's running I don't know seven
minute pace or something like that and
it just looked so smooth and easy and
and fun it was really remarkable it
really stayed with we'll give you the
idea to tuck in rather than run next to
him and try it well I was I was like I
need to I want to learn if I can get in
lockstep with him and I know Eric this
is you know a lot of a lot of your tools
and your drills are kind of similar in
that regard I mean it was just
instinctual I think at that moment but
most people don't do that and it was an
education to me the first time someone
said get in the right type behind me I
always thought you were next to somebody
right did with you initially right get
as close behind you know I don't know if
I was that close to him but right you
know I was trying to kind of track him
and uh it was a really cool experience
and you know I remember when I was
wrapping my head around like
uh the experience that we're gonna have
today I was recalling attending a book
event it must have been
Born to Run had been out a little bit so
maybe it was 2010 it was a book soup in
West Hollywood and you weren't there I
Was Born to Run event but Scott was
scotchuric was kind of hosting it and he
was telling stories from the book and
from his you know career and experience
and I just remember uh it was my first
time meeting Scott in person and we were
both like in the midst of writing our
own books at the same time and I'm just
coveting this like massive uh you know
sort of imposter syndrome right because
I had this opportunity to write this
book here's Scott he's the the greatest
Ultra runner ever also vegan I'm like
well you know why is anyone going to
read my book and then I'm reading Born
to Run and I'm hearing these stories and
I'm like what am I even doing right I
should remember and I also remember
um Peter sarsgaard was there
and I was actually because I see there
that were you I was do you remember this
I don't think I met you I don't remember
meeting you yeah we had done a run
earlier in the day up in uh Griffith
Park
and then had that event afterwards but
because Peter and Scott was there I was
trying to give them all the mic time and
I kind of had a feeling oh you know what
I think we've all heard enough talking
so I think I came on and said thanks
everybody and that was like almost the
only thing that is I mean it's a vague
memory right
my recollection is that Peter was there
because at that time
there was an effort to turn the book
into a movie and Jake Gyllenhaal was
involved I know he showed up at
Leadville and there was a lot of energy
around that and then like what my first
thing is like what happened yeah it all
fell apart or what what transpired
that's an episode in itself right well
it's kind of cool so
let's look at the Rosier glass half full
part which was it was a really fun
experience what happened was Peter was
on the set of Green Lantern and he had
almost like massive prosthetic makeup
they were putting on it was like a
four-hour process so he was reading Born
to Run someone like slapped into his
hands when he's in the makeup chair he's
reading this book and then at one point
he said I got out of the chair and
called my manager and said I really want
to be involved in this film at that
point producers had it but they didn't
have a director or screen reader they
had a screener but not directed so Peter
calls up and he said I would love to
direct this film I'm an aspiring kind of
baby Runner myself so Peter got involved
and I first got wind to this when I got
a phone call at home from one of the
producers one of The Producers saying
hey
we know that Leadville races in a couple
weeks would you be interested in going
and camping out there with Jake
Gyllenhaal and Peter sarsgaard
and I'm like yeah I could probably clear
out my schedule to go camping with Jake
Jones and so then Eric and I plays on
out there but these guys were going to
like you know bushwhack and be up on the
mountain in like a pup tent and I'm like
you know dude I did enough of that stuff
no thanks so we run we rented uh cabins
down by uh Twin Lakes these little
rustic cabins and the first night these
guys arrived like a freaking Monsoon
blew in and the next day we got a little
knock on the doors Peter and Jake like
drenched to the Bone like hey uh can we
come in and dry off yeah so that to me
was a lifelong memory was Jake
Gyllenhaal occupying my little bathroom
taking a hot shower and coming out I
just remember the aroma like oh you know
like Aroma of Jake is really good like
whatever product he uses like
eucalyptusy
uh so we spent a nice weekend there uh
Jake is a fantastic athlete and a fun
dude a good guy to hang out with Peter
likewise
and um but what happened basically to
cut to the end of it was that
it became so mired in what the story was
and this was a particular challenge for
me writing the book I wrote an entire
draft we can get into some writerliness
yeah her entire draft of the book and
turned it in and my editor called me a
week later and he goes yeah um
you should think about starting over
they literally trash a hundred thousand
words and I knew he was right
um It's A Hard story to tell because
there's a lot of chainsaws juggling at
the same time and I think what happened
with that uh sarsgard Gyllenhaal
attempt was they just got stuck in the
quicksand of what story is it and they
just kind of churn in the mud for years
trying to get a screenplay together and
it didn't work never never panned out
yeah to me I mean on on on the surface
it appears to be a very difficult book
to translate into a you know cinematic
narrative but my sense was always that
the story lies with caballo blanco like
it's Mike a true story so you have to
show you have to like go on that journey
through his point of view not yours and
the stuff that that you know you talk
about in the book can come in but the
arc really is Micah and if you tell that
story then you can with tangents tell
talk about all the other things that was
that was the direction of it but it
wasn't unfortunately uh but that was the
Revelation that I had was you know I
first tried to write the story I come
from a magazine writing background which
is like you got to smack people in the
face quick get their attention and keep
their attention and so to me the most
dramatic moment in the story is when you
get these two hard partying Surfers and
suddenly they're lost in the Gila in the
Chihuahua Back Country and this could be
it for them so I kept trying to open the
book with Jen and Billy going off on
Iran and then Vanishing
but there's way too much backstory to be
folded in and then after turning in a
draft with that starting point and my
editor said you know once you shred it
and start over I had to take the step
back and I realized the same thing this
is caballo's story the beginning middle
and end is all Micah and the story has
got to track him and that's when I
understood like how to tell the story
yeah and the conclusion to the Micah
true AKA Cabello Blanco story had yet to
be fully written when the book came out
it has since been written and there's
something interesting about where we are
right now we're in Agora Hills right so
can you talk a little bit about how that
chapter finally concluded after the book
yeah it's funny because Eric and I were
talking about this in a way over it
might have been like 10 years almost
almost within a few months 10 years to
the moment of where we are now when this
all happened wow I was here and it's
eerily familiar to me because I was here
at the Agora Hills Library uh they had
asked me to come in to do a book event
and at the time I was researching my my
next book Natural Born Heroes and
through a very tenuous series of
connections I had arranged to have a
breakfast with Rick Rubin you know Ace
music producer Rick Rubin
for that research on that book
and all this is happening I'm flying in
I'm trying to arrange this breakfast
with Rick Rubin and my phone dies on the
way here and I arrive at the library and
get out of the car and there's someone
very anxious looking at the door and
sees me and just starts bustling over to
me very concerned and they get up to me
and they go thank God you're here I go I
think I'm on time right no it's not that
Maria is trying to reach you I don't
think I know any Maria's and he hands me
the phone and I return the call to
whoever it is it's Maria and it turns
out it was kamaya's girlfriend
Maria Walton and she's oh thank God I
reached you Mike is missing and like
well that's kind of what the dude does
you know he was always missing and maybe
just explain a little bit about who this
guy is if you know for the people who
have not read more in Iran it's a kind
of contextualize it a little bit so
Micah true
has always lived in my mind as sort of
half man half ghost there's a guy that
is always there but not there when I
first heard about him I was in Mexico
City
on the sign of the New York Times
magazine I was supposed to be tracking
down known associates of a woman in
Gloria Trevi who's a hugely famous
Mexican pop singer and she was accused
of secretly running this brainwashing
sex cult and then going on the lamb so
you think a story like that is gonna
occupy your attention but when I
traveled from Mexico City into Chihuahua
I kept noticing these pictures of people
in a running posture wearing like
dresses and sandals and in my hotel
there was a little magazine and they
explained that this group were the
taromada and they could run hundreds of
miles in the fitness of sandals and
they're doing it deep in the old age at
the time I was a discouraged had long
given up on running I was a big dude
like 260 pounds and had been told by
doctors that running is bad for
every human body particularly bodies
like yours
and so I'm looking at this magazine and
I'm thinking to myself there's no way
this crap is true you know there's
nobody running a hundred miles I'd never
heard of an ultra marathon you know the
marathon was the ultimate Challenge
right Philippines died
they're saying this guy ran four
marathons in flip-flops in a dress and
he's 72 years old like no way
but I kept seeing these images on the
license plates you go into a little taco
shop and there's a picture on the wall
so I started to ask around and they say
oh those are the taramada and they're
down in the Copper Canyon and they
they're hard to find but they're amazing
runners
so I think well this is cool I can
double dip on my assignments as a
freelancer I'll just get a story for
runners world out of this in and out a
couple interviews you know double pay
find a guy takes me down to the Copper
Canyon we actually after a week of
searching locate a taramara village and
discover that the way you remain a
reclusive tribe is like not talking to
strangers but they did tell me about a
guy a guy they called caballo blanco the
White Horse they said you should go talk
to that guy
and 50 of my mind is like great and the
other 50 is like they're just trying to
get me out of town
so when I finally uh tracked this guy
down Micah true
it was just like they had described he
was a big tall dude who had come down to
the Copper Canyons from Netherlands
Colorado
in search of the same thing I was
looking for but when he found that he
never left he'd been down there from his
15 years at that point running with the
turtle Mata and sort of mimicking not
just their running but their lifestyle
like he felt that he had discovered
something very powerful and
life-changing and at the point where he
never wanted to leave
and he was running upwards of 170 miles
a week or something like that right just
like unbelievable mileage here's the
thing about it so Louis Escobar our
friend who came down with us later he
would say that cabayo's range was
unlimited and that's what really stuck
in my brain was it wasn't like he was
doing X number of miles per day is that
the world was his playground whatever he
felt like doing he had the range to go
do it wow so this guy becomes the
central figure the protagonist in in
Born to Run and all the stories are kind
of through his lived experience and what
can be gleaned about the nature of
running the human body Etc and all the
stuff that you talk about with
minimalism
um but true to his word Micah true right
he's living this very off-the-grid
lifestyle for a very long period of time
and
um in the wake of the book coming out at
some point goes missing when you're out
here in Agora Hills
so one of to me one of the happiest
accomplishments of the book Born to Run
is that cabio got a girlfriend
and he got a killer girl from Maria
Walton right now dude she's a dream just
loving tough smart and like everything
he needed like
yeah he got a
email out of the blue from some woman
Say Hey I want to train for a race I
like the book
and he's
like he gave her some kind of a Kurt
rude response and she was not to be
dissuaded and uh they became you know uh
they became boyfriend and girlfriend
so she was the one who reached out to me
and said hey he's missing and I'm like
yeah well you know what do you expect
yeah but then she said something that
really caught my attention she said uh
he left wadahuco tied up
and overnight is like wolf dog his wolf
dog is the only way to describe wada
huko and that really caught my eye
because this I was in Boulder once
and kabaya was back in the States and he
shows up at this like furry Tony
Boutique Brew Pub and he walks in with
this freaking wolf on a chain and it's
in a cast because this dog had never
been out of the copper can he literally
had like adopted a feral creature and
made it you know his partner and she
shows up in Boulder and the first day
this dog like walks in front of a bus
and gets hit and so there's a cast on
its leg and so goodbye was like carrying
this thing around brings it to our table
and this dog is like snapping at
people's food at other tables and kabaya
was just like no problem
but uh so he was in Inseparable from
wadahuco he would never ever leave that
dog tied up and so Maria tells me this
I'm like again walking into an event a
speaking event there's an audience there
and I got this phone call my phone's
dead and I said well wow okay
um have you talked on Lewis Lewis
Escobar
and Lewis is a character under himself
because
he's the one guy I wish there was more
of and Born to Run but there's just so
many big personalities Lewis almost got
a little bit sidelined but he he's kind
of like
he's the uncle you know he is the steady
Uncle that's life at a party but at the
same time in a pinch you're in jail you
call Uncle Lou so I said Maria have you
called uh Lewis and she said oh yeah
he's on his way so then I bought a guy's
phone call Louis and Louis is typical
driving out of Santa Barbara he's
texting people driving with his knees
and he's on his way down to the Hilo
Wilderness uh in New Mexico where kabaya
was last seen so I sorry dude I got this
talk I'll be done I'll drop off my
rental pick me up at LAX and that's what
happened right so you go down there and
the ultra running Community kind of
turns up for this man hunt right Scott
jurich shows up I think Timmy Olsen show
up as well a bunch of people Skaggs
Brothers turned up except for one
notable character
Barefoot Ted
because he had a different
perspective on what might have been
happening so we're so Lewis picks me up
at LAX and uh I jump in his truck and he
already had like two other people and
we're bombing down the highway we swing
over to pull up Pat Sweeney who jumps in
a lot of people I'd never met but it was
the kind of weird orbit that had
developed around Micah which is it
within a year or two of the book coming
out suddenly people who were fellow
Spirits had connected with him and loved
him and so I'm like in his truck with
like I know Lewis like who knows
everybody else and they're racing to the
rescue
so we're bombing down the highway and oh
yeah I think people are venmoing money
to Lewis like I'll pay for your gas you
guys gonna need Taco Bell so his phone's
dang we had to shove him in the back
seat because dude you cannot be driving
anymore
and um on the way I get a message from
Ted
which is the
the most infuriating but loving thing
about Ted which is he says stuff that
just makes you want to just rip his head
off but in the in retrospect it's true
so he can send the message like he's an
acquired taste is exactly right I feel
like
the closer I get to Ted the more anxious
I get and the further away I get the
more I love him so there's like a
magnetic polarization uh-huh and so he
sent me this message like he's like why
are you going down there he predicted
this and he said that someday man I'm
just gonna walk off into the Wilderness
like Geronimo and lie down and that will
be my end I'm like Ted
and you know we're trying to help this
dude like why are you saying he's dead
but that was it Ted I think if Ted
tentative super loving guy yeah there's
never a no that comes out of his mouth
much as he drives me crazy you ask Ted a
favor he'll double it
but in this instance he's like no it's
over which was infuriating but
yeah he was right so you know eventually
the body is found wasn't he
sort of at a creek bed with his his feet
or his legs in the water
and it was unclear like they did an
autopsy there's a lot of uncertainty
about how and why he died
um the conventional isn't the
conventional wisdom that it was some
kind of fidipides cardio myopathy but
you have a different view on that don't
you
so it was a weird scene we get down
there it's Sun up search and rescue is
super well equipped to deal with this
they know the Gila and then Lewis
Escobar gets right up in the face of the
head Searcher and he goes uh he knows
something you got some of the greatest
Ultra runners in the world standing in
front of you you should cut them loose
and this got his credit because this
could have turned into a disaster
something you have 15 people missing and
he's like okay
quadranting off you know go to town and
then just launched you know Kyle Skaggs
Scott George everyone just pouring off
in every direction to run through the
mountains and what's weird is
to a scientific fact they knew he had to
be north of the age of the Park Station
because his night has been seen running
right up the highway that the times
figured out he had to be north of there
so for three days we're searching this
every crevice like not a sign of the guy
and a couple guys who had known Micah
for a long time ago well if he
absolutely has me North he's South and
they just turn around with the opposite
direction and then very quickly they
found him yeah his his corpse Lying by
the side of a creek and in some eerily
irritatingly Barefoot Ted way it was the
most beautiful final resting spot you
can imagine
so they did an autopsy they thought it
was cardiomyopathy but other endurance
athletes with Science Background said
every endurance athlete has got an
oversized Heart Like that's nothing they
just haven't dissected enough endurance
athletes
their estimate which seems to me the one
that has the most fruit is that he had a
parasitic Invader in his body because he
he'd had these fainting spells on
occasion where he'd just drop over and
uh he contacted he thought he had Wes
Nile for a while for about three months
he was just flat on his back and this
was not
too much prior to the incident yeah and
so I had to believe that he would have
had an undiagnosed you know sort of a
tropical parasite that was probably you
know car in the way it is um at his
heart
Mythic figure who lived you know the way
he wanted to live and you know died in a
in a in a manner befitting you know who
he was you know it's kind of an
incredible story yeah yeah I hate to
mythologize it too much but you know he
talked about this old west figure that
just want to head out into the hindrance
and carve his own little lifestyle and
to find like-minded Souls among the
taramada
oh yeah he was he was at home yeah how
do you think about balancing you know
that kind of fidelity to principle with
like being you know somebody who lives
in the world and you know has a family
Etc like there's so much to be learned
from that type of Courage
but also you know you have a different
mission right so how do you like wed
those two things to try to you know
create the life uh that on some level
you know takes the best of what he had
to teach us
you know it's a fundamental question
that I've asked myself a lot because not
only do I ask you how he lived this way
but when I look back on that whole
adventure of Born to Run I'm like what's
everybody doing here like why is Scott
York here of all places why isn't the
bottom of a canyon with some race by
some dude who he doesn't even know why
are Jen and Billy here why is Eric
Horton here Eric has a very successful
coaching business in Jackson Hole why
isn't El Paso getting on a Greyhound bus
and over time I realized that I think
all those people involved in that
Adventure we're looking for the same
thing they're trying to find a way where
they can turn the thing they love into a
lifestyle not just Recreation not just
the 45 minutes you carve out you know
when you're on the treadmill in the
afternoon
and I think the answer in the end comes
down to that this idea of
I think too many of us start to stray
into the world of exercise as
punishments as a test of our inner worth
and I think every person down there and
you can look at Scott is a very
particular example
is exercise is a sense of like
joyfulness of creativity of artistry and
Artistry can take any kind of form but
if you believe that your abilities to
create not just to destroy not to beat
somebody else beat yourself up beat down
your body but to really create and and
relish then you start to get on the
cabayo path that's really the secret
sauce of Born to Run success right I've
heard you talk about this quite a bit
like when people ask you like why did
this book break out and become such a
massive hit like in retrospect looking
back this idea being that running it
wasn't a narrative about running as uh
you know a suffering vehicle for
personal growth which is kind of like
what my book's about right but it was
about finding the joy in the community
right that that this should be a joyous
expansive experience that's that's fun
and it's your journey journey towards
discovering that for yourself oh but I
would I would counter I would I would
rebut your point because you were on a
path to a lot of unhappiness and pain
and destruction and you found something
that sort of hurt glow yeah um but I'm
curious so your writing process uh what
was that like for you so it was a long
period the sort of Dark Knights of the
Soul like am I ever going to finish this
you're trying to flip it on me right
well it tells you a little bit but this
is about you but yeah I mean it was look
it was my first book and I don't have a
you know a history or a career of being
a journalist so it was definitely yeah a
lot of you know Dark Knights of the soul
and panicking and like I said imposter
syndrome and the like like I just was
delighted that I had a book deal I
couldn't even believe that like somebody
was like really so you know I was
determined to
you know write the most
uh you know authentic version of this
story that I possibly could because as I
mentioned earlier and I've said this
before I knew Scott was writing a book
and I was like well my book can't be
anything like that and it shouldn't be
anything like that like what do I have
that's unique to me that could be
helpful to other people and I realized
that the value of what I had to say was
going to be deeply wet to the extent to
which I was willing to be honest and
vulnerable about like my own pain and my
own foibles and failures because that
would be the emotional like connective
tissue that could hopefully speak to a
broader audience Beyond just like the
running Community right like I I my goal
was to write a book that wouldn't just
live within running circles but connect
and speak to you know a broader audience
of people which you did so beautifully
and successfully
um you know mine wasn't nearly as
successful as yours but you know I'm
proud of what I was able to do you're
doing okay Rich yeah well this is a
different thing here but anyway
um that was it that was it
you were writing a book about
athletes for people who may not be
athletes and that was my
total orientation for Born to Run was
like the sports movies I love the most
are sports I don't give a crap about you
know like Bulldog yeah right uh Tin Cup
I don't think I've ever hit a golf ball
I will die a happy man if I never do hit
a golf ball but I will watch the crap
out of 10 cup mm-hmm bulldorem I don't
play baseball don't watch baseball love
the movie and that was my thoughts like
if I can take this activity everybody
thinks it's one thing and if I can show
them another side of it and I think you
had the same orientation like if I could
take my story and just not really about
hammering my butt in triathlons but it's
really about letting yourself explore
and discover
and I think the other there's a freedom
which I think we probably both had which
is you're not quite sure if anyone's
ever going to read this yeah and at the
time I wrote Born to Run the running
bookshelf was pretty thin it was ultra
marathon man which was a great adventure
and then a bunch of stuff about how not
to get chafed right like shorts really
practical type books and regurgitating
this stuff for murakami
you know although I'll tell you that was
right around I'm not sure if that was
before or after born and runs almost at
the same time yeah but even then I was
willing to say I'm in a different
category I'm a different age group
because you know he's a super successful
novelist and I'm some jiboney magazine
writer so
but I think that was it that you and I
had
um a common experience of feeling like
we could say what we wanted and to be as
uh open and exposed because there's a
good chance no one's going to read this
yeah Eric I promise we're going to get
no you're fine you're fine
um go ahead what I you can see I'm a
lucky man I've been uh two and a half
weeks with this guy hearing all these
stories yeah well he's a very skilled
Storyteller so you know we're good you
could buy you a spirit animal for Eric
was El Gavilan the hawk yeah it's
hovering above watching yeah and then
dropping the talons yeah
um two observations on what you just
said the first being uh that you know on
this on this kind of
um
spectrum of suffering to Joy in terms of
our relationship to Fitness and running
in particular you know my I I would
still submit that like my book was about
like how suffering can be a tool and a
teacher for personal expansion and
growth but I also think it's a it's an
unsustainable fuel source like now you
know we're about the same age maybe
almost exactly the same age like now my
relationship to it is so much different
like the joy finding the joy and doing
it for the joy as opposed to a
performance goal or you know some kind
of self-flagellation is much more
appealing exciting and ultimately more
expansive right and that's what you know
we're going to get into the the new book
but that's a huge message of of this new
book like Born to Run being
kind of the
the why and Born to Run 2 being the how
isn't it funny that
fun is like a dirty word in Endurance
Sports
fun I enjoyed it I had a good time like
no dude you're not serious man it's got
to be you know run yourself into the ER
or you didn't leave it all on the table
and to me like that's
the Gap in our human evolution as
athletes we start off that way as kids
and it's it's been funny we've been we
were at a group run in Chinatown New
York run for Chinatown and as we were
talking to Leland you
as he's describing his own uh immersion
to running these little kids are just
ripping around back and forth in the
playground I feel like why are we
talking to you dude we should be talking
to these kids because what they figured
out is it but what happens is we sort of
take kids when you sort of pin them up
in their desks and over the time by the
time you're ready to get back out and
move again You've Lost That Fun
component but it's again ancestry it's
so important
um
yeah
um
Born to Run was not an instant New York
Times bestseller I think that would
surprise a lot of people oh yeah like
it's kind of amazing the Grassroots work
heavy lifting and campaign that you
devoted yourself to to get this book out
there and the difference between kind of
how people perceive that book Now versus
what you were actually doing when it
came out
I still don't know nobody know what
happened I don't know when the
electricity started to spread but the
book came out in May of 2009 and the
first I kick off events that my
publisher had arranged for me was to
have a talk in a running shoe store in
New York this is a book which says that
running shoes are the the cause of all
evil in the no world and they put me
into a running shoe store and there's
about three people there and sort of
talk to them and don't know what I'm
doing they left and that was the end of
that event and did a couple others go to
a bookstore talk to four or five
basically friends that was it so after a
week book tour is over book is not
reviewed at all uh Runners no reviews at
all to this day Runner's World has never
written an article about born and run
get out will not touch it because it's
too offensive to its Advertiser base
I don't know I don't know I can take
guesses but you know I think it's so I
mean four million how many how many
copies of this book have you sold four
million copies yeah in that range so
early on it's May 2009 this book is
going out like a flickering candle
and I'm thinking I'm not I'm not done
yet you know I got more to do and I'm
thinking to myself you know every day
there are people getting together to run
I just got to go to where they are
rather than telling them to come to me
so I was living in Lancaster
Pennsylvania so I went to my local
bookstore said hey can I buy 100 copies
of books from you and I bought them cash
out of my pocket and then I'd resell
them so if there was a 5K race I'd Rock
up open the back of the truck have a box
of books there and say guys give me two
seconds before you run got this book May
really dig it um there's a handsome guy
on the cover Millie Barnett and that
kind of stuff and you know at a raised
people I've got other things on their
mind than buying a thing that they now
have to carry around but bit by bit it
started to gather and then I would start
to show up at races and people had
already heard about the book and we're
kind of curious about getting a copy
they'd only have one or two copies in a
Barnes and Noble at a time so they're
they're selling out fast
and I would show up with 30 books in my
truck and that was it May June July just
kind of you know hucking and hucking it
and then out of the blue I get a phone
call
it was August I remember this because I
was supposed to go back to Portugal I
used to work as a foreign correspondent
visit friends for a birthday and I got a
call say hey
um John Stewart would like to have you
on The Daily Show
like the week after next you got a
little opening right before they go on
hiatus they go you know it's actually
not not a really good time can we
reschedule it and they no
no we can't uh-huh idiot and something
all right fine I'll go in the Jon
Stewart show and uh so his
producer's husband was a big fan of the
book Jon Stewart had a producer and
producer's husband was a member of the
Central Park Track Club and the husband
was just like on his wife and John you
got to get this book on whatever so I
get unload the backstory of how it
actually happened but then lo and behold
like seven days later I'm walking onto
The Daily Show and that's when you know
right that was the big inflection point
and then did you end up hitting the New
York Times list after that
it might have been on just before that I
don't recall but that was to me the
surprise when I when I snuck on to the
best seller list there's the list and
there's the extended list and all of a
sudden whoa there's like the 15 and
there's the extended list and they'll
say hey Born to Run look at that it
might have been just before that and
then it just built from there and it
continues to sell like if you go on
Amazon it's always the number one book
in the running category and probably in
you know the broader Sports category as
well crazy man you and me man back and
forth right I'm way below you know it's
like dude there's a huge gap there
brother I don't think so that's all
right you know yeah
um I mean that's really inspiring to uh
you know see the power that grass you
know grass movements like that you know
still hold to get a message out there
that's worthy of being heard and you
know the power of just sharing one to
one to one like people just saying this
is a great book check it out it's very
cool but I'm sure a lot of people told
you not to write a follow-up Born to Run
two a sequel I think you compare it to
Vin Diesel
right yeah yeah yeah authors what are
you doing fast and furious seven you
know touch that
so here's what happened here's an untold
part of the story that you don't know
Rich uh I was actually contracted to
write another book I was writing a book
called King of The Weekend Warriors
and the idea was that there are
extremely high performing endurance
athletes out there that most people have
never heard of because they don't care
about podiums or anything and I got a
buddy in New York he's got seven
different Guinness World Records he gets
intrigued by an idea for instance he
wanted to be the person to do the
fastest Traverse of the entire New York
City subway system at the time he was
working for a bank and he hacked into
the Mainframe computer of the bank and
started running the millions of
computation to figure out the best
Traverse of the New York City subway
system it's an extremely complicated
mathematical equation and he figured it
out he came up with a plan and then he
trained for it because it's a very real
physical challenge you get a Sprint
between stations and you got to map
things out you got to go to one station
down to another running in the tunnels
or no you're on the streets
but It's Tricky so you have to hit every
single stop faster than anybody else and
a number of people have done this over
the years it's one of those like
underground records where people like it
because it's a mathematical like
tri-level chess uh problem it also has a
physical component so my buddy figures
this out he has a plan and he goes off
and does it and he breaks the world
record he has the world record for the
highest Ascent in 12 hours so the most
vertical feat gained in 12 hours and the
way he did it was he had his wife
standing at the top of a skyscraper of a
building that he had an office in and
she held the elevator for 12 hours so he
would run up the stairs rolling the
elevator he hit down come off the
elevator hit you know 75 whatever the
top floor was he'd run up the stairs
he'd do this for 12 hours up and down up
and down his poor wife hold door hold
the door
but I was fascinated by this guy because
I would say to him hey you know how
about this you should jump into one of
the backyard challenges he's like dude I
would never do that and he could explain
his logic that's you against other
people right I'm against me Sam I want
to write this book but I'll tell you why
and this is going to come across as
offensive to some people and I don't yes
I do sort of mean it that way to me
where I realized halfway through the
book was I'm not writing a story for the
right reasons I'm writing this to wave a
finger at David Goggins and say dude
you're wrong you know you should not end
your race on
floor in the emergency room you should
end with a smile on your face and sense
of achievement and I felt like I'm not
writing I'm arguing and I just felt the
wind coming out of my sails as I worked
in this book I'm not telling a story for
the joy sheer Joy of it I'm telling a
story because I feel like I know
something and I'm going to argue with
this guy and just soured on me
and I'm thinking to myself that's the
wrong reason so what is the right reason
at the time I get a lot of messages all
the time from people asking me for
training advice and I'm like
you can do better but don't ask me you
know I'm not that guy
and then like that day I'm opening up my
inbox and there's like 10 messages hey
I've got planner fasciitis what should I
do you know what shoes should I buy and
it's just clicked the book you should be
writing is the book that people have
been asking for but I never felt I was
in a position to do it I just didn't
know enough
and then I thought but I know someone
who does
we really need to take everything that
was not inborn to run and putting the
board in a run too sure I feel like most
people wanna eat better they want to
improve their diets absolutely have you
heard of it I've heard of it this trips
up so many people we thought hey we know
a couple things about how to do this a
few so we created this thing called the
plant power meal planner that is this
beautiful offering whereby you gain
access to literally thousands of
plant-based recipes that you can totally
customize based upon your preferences
your allergies your peccadillos it
integrates with grocery delivery so all
the ingredients that you need get
shipped right to your door so you can
make the stuff that you've pre-selected
and we all could use a little
inspiration and support when preparing
meals for our families in our busy lives
so we hope you join us no matter what
your eating style is we have our arms
open wide and we've saved saved you a
space at our family table to join us in
eating more healthy vibrant plant-based
meals and if you're looking for the
perfect holiday gift for a loved one
right now for a limited time we're
offering twenty dollars off meal planner
gift cards through December 15th visit
meals.ritroll.com to claim the offer
again for twenty dollars off meal
planner gift cards from now until
December 15th visit meals Dot
richroll.com
[Laughter]
so that that brings us up to you Eric
um why don't we start at the at the
beginning here like how did you first
meet Christopher and what was the
process of of getting him ready for that
first
50k race that he wanted to run I mean
the whole thing with Born to Run is
about how you didn't see yourself as a
runner you thought those days were in
the past and
um you know I'm a big guy and knees and
Etc and all that kind of junk and you
really rewired his thinking and created
an approach that you know basically
allowed this guy to Blossom and become
you know an ambassador of of the sport
in a in the broadest sense of the the
word yeah so we first met in oh five
he was doing a magazine article on my
training in Jackson Hole and it was
right when he came back from the Copper
Canyon the first time
and I'm like you just did what because I
I moved to Colorado
in
91 and it's right when the taramara who
had raced Leadville 100 so they just
came on my radar I'm like oh man this is
this is this is legit and um and that
was back when there was no internet you
know the mythology of what they're doing
was proliferated because you couldn't
find any information about them so here
I am
like walking into meeting this guy who
just spent time with them and we just
kind of hit it off and so we were
supposed to do a two-day kind of I was
like the flavor of the month for this
magazine article and it was like
America's greatest workout or something
something right crazy like that and so
he we met day one I kind of went through
what I had scripted and then it came
really really obvious to me here's a guy
who really really wants to run can't
doesn't think he can been told he can't
and I ripped up my script for day two
and we went to work and and at that
point of time I think you know how we
kind of explore this is super important
because I think a lot of people watching
and listening see themselves in that way
and I'm kind of going through something
right now you know that has forced me to
reframe like how I think about my my
running and I'm curious to explore that
with you as well but at that time were
you would you consider yourself to be
kind of a traditional running coach did
your approach change as a result of your
exposure to this new way or had you
already kind of cottoned on to this more
minimal naturalistic approach to
training and lifestyle it's just been a
lifelong you know I was an athlete
growing up so I've always looked back
and all these little points in my life
that have really
just accumulated
so at that time when I met Chris
um
I I just kind of have a feel for what an
athlete needs
and it's it's
a combination of research
School knowledge
my awareness of my own body my awareness
of seeing athletes good and bad you know
and sometimes seeing bad is really
really helpful
um and and then knowing the psyche of
the athlete you know the
what was most important with Chris and I
was for me to see his desire to run and
being so frustrated that he can't and
knowing a lot more about Chris now is
that that what that was the rebel in him
he really wanted to run because
everyone's told him he can
um and so
it's then just I mean in I I can't it's
just a feeling of from a coach of what
what an individual athlete needs right
so in CR in the in the case of Chris
though he comes to you and you have this
Keen observational ability to kind of
look at someone their posture how they
walk Etc and immediately hone in and
identify like oh here's what's up and
here's what we need to work on so what
is that process like so for Chris it was
it was two things it was one just kind
of dialing into the form you know and
for me that that's that's an easy part
um but it was also starting to see that
really specifically what he was doing
that was causing some of the trouble
that he was encountering is that he he
didn't have the ability to run easy
you know we go out for our nice long
conversational zone two run he really
didn't have that ability so every time
he went out it was kind of morphed into
this moderate effort that was breaking
him down his own effort exactly right so
was that a fitness thing or was that
like a heavy foot form technique it was
both it was both
um but it was it was I think
precipitated by the form is that he he
did not have the efficiency to run easy
and that's what we really dove into and
and I I think too the third part was
most importantly in that visit that
initial visit was me
really giving him the confidence that
there was a solution
and I think you know that that's just my
own according to give his own right just
just the idea that there possibly could
be a solution absolutely it is and was
revelatory because there was this idea
and you talk about it in foreign too
like like don't teach people technique
when it comes to running like everyone's
an out of one and there is no right or
wrong way and we all know how to run so
you just go out and run and like don't
mess around with that which is insane
when you deconstruct that like you use
the example of like the basketball
player like you don't just throw the
ball up in the air and hope for the best
like you it's a skill just like anything
else and there is a right way and a
wrong way and so much about our you know
modern Lifestyles and we can get into
all of that drive us into situations
where we're compelled to do it
improperly and that leads to all of
these you know injuries and persistent
you know problems that sideline people
unnecessarily when you you asked how I
kind of developed all this is one of my
personal experiences I was living at
Colorado at the time and doing a ton of
running doing a ton of bike racing and
decided to go to Triathlon route and had
no swim background so here I am I think
the week before I'd won a bike race so
fit and I decided to start swimming well
I had to go like the last hour of the
rec center hours that they were open and
swim the width because I had a hard time
getting just from one end to the other
and I'm like this isn't a fitness thing
this is an efficiency thing that can
translate to any any activity yeah sure
I mean that's
that's like a reference I'm always
banging this drum because I come from a
swimming background and so I learned
proper technique very early and you know
being a triathlete and training with
other triathletes who learn swimming
later in life I just watch them fighting
the water their technique is terrible
but they're they're time crunched and
their main concern is the fitness part
of it right like I got to get this much
distance in and this much time it
doesn't matter I'll do the technique
later and I'm like bro you should just
forget about the whole thing and start
at the beginning
um so why wouldn't that apply to running
it's the same thing yep yep yep and and
I think
you know I I tell a lot of beginning
runners
don't view starting running
as a workout or as a form of Fitness or
a way to lose weight
create the joy first
and everything else will follow and that
goes into learning to be efficient and
not thinking it has to be hard and
that's that's kind of what we really
dove into with Chris is that I worked
kind of the real easy end but also he
did a lot of Hill Sprints and a lot of
other higher effort training to develop
that efficiency and economy that was you
know revelatory you know he was in a
matter of a couple weeks doing so much
more than he had ever done just be by
changing things up yeah and and so Chris
from your perspective what was that like
hooking up with Eric I mean it'd be one
thing like maybe when you first met him
you're like oh well we'll do this one
thing together but you guys have gone on
this like lifetime adventure together so
obviously like this guy's been Central
to you know everything that you care
about in this world
you can see why just from that answer
yeah it's so smart and so easy to
appreciate and absorb but
um yeah so I'm super grateful on a
personal note because he gave me
something that has changed everything
um not from a career standpoint but just
from a physical standpoint imagine being
told you can't run believing it stopping
it and then 15 years years later
realized I can walk out the door and run
as far as I want in any direction the
whole thing we're talking about with
cabio that that freedom that Joy I mean
someone's giving you just an
incalculable presence so
you know I just owe you a ton right so
so here we go we got Born to Run two and
this really is it is the how it's like
this manual that walks you through
um these essentially like these seven
principles these like pillars for
lifelong athleticism that all
conveniently start with the letter F
right I don't know that we need to go
Siri Adam through the whole thing but
um you know uh you know let's like let's
hone in on the on the on the form piece
for a little bit I think with with Born
to Run
um
it became a little bit reductive in the
sense that everyone just thought it was
about minimalism and barefoot running
and that is a piece in there for sure
right but that's really kind of evidence
of a broader uh you know concept around
form technique and and lifestyle so I
don't that's not really a question but
like maybe we can launch into how you
guys are thinking about that I mean Born
to Run huge huge and ushering in this
minimalism sensibility with running and
it's been interesting to kind of watch
the pendulum swing both ways like it was
all about Vibrams for a while and then I
remember I I was helping to crew Dean
carnaz is at bad waters you know some
handful of years after that and every
single person was wearing hokas with the
giant marshmallow you know souls and I
still have yet to see Elites
um
running in minimal Footwear for the most
part I mean I'm sure there's exceptions
and you guys probably know these guys
but it's not like everyone's Towing the
line in sandals at Leadville or anything
oh but the elites do yeah no one's lined
up for a marathon and a pair of Hocus
you know they're wearing the most I mean
the most more cushioned ones if you're
running on Elite Marathon you had the
thinnest those are it's a minimal shoe
right well you have the Nike whatever
it's called and all of that all the high
temperature and stuff I'm sure you have
lots of opinions about all that kind of
stuff you know but you know it is weird
like it had you know the the shoe the
shoe company still Prevail for the most
part like they've taken a note from the
work that you've done but I don't know
like what's your sense of where all that
is right now Chris is more of a purist
than from that standpoint from me as a
coach and myself you know I live in
Jackson Hole running the Tetons so for
me my number one kind of decision making
um process as far as shoe choice is
what's going to give me the most
protection that day based on where I'm
running so I I need Rock protection so
I'm trying to go as minimal as possible
but still allow me to have that
protection I need to you know rocks hurt
and um and based on the performance that
I want that day so but one step back is
that I think the further we get away
from the ground in a shoe the more we
are getting away from allowing our feet
to work in a natural environment and I
think what people really need to
understand is that how we use our feet
really dictate how we stabilize you know
our first line of defense as Runners is
with our big toe and our Arch that's our
stabilizer and that really dictates how
well we use our glutes
so how we use our feet directly relate
to how we've kind of hear the important
stability strength we need to be healthy
strong performance or longevity-based
Runners and that comes to our feet so
pick and chew you know I I use shoes as
a tool sure yeah yeah yeah I mean I I
think it you know there is this idea in
the book like it's it's not that running
Barefoot or bare you know minimal shoes
are are this Panacea like you say you
could you could just strap those on but
if your form is terrible you're still
going to get injured right like we have
to even step further back
um and really evaluate like how do you
hold your body and what are the
activities that you're you know annured
to on a daily basis that are leading you
astray and you have all of these cool
like really simple you know drills to
kind of get a meter on like where you're
at like the The Rock Lobster thing you
know that kind of stuff it's great it's
amazing how to talk a little bit about
that is it's crazy how well that works
but here's here's my take on this rich
is I come from a perspective of like I
am
the guy that's always like one cushion
shoe away from backsliding we were at a
great store in uh North Carolina relapse
totally yeah well I would be very
cautious about that word you know but
we're in a running shoe store and I've
always been curious to try the ultra
Escalante racer it's actually the shoe
we recommend in the book if you were
transitioning if you're trying to get
your form dialed in I've been very
scrupulous to never even during the
vegan five finger phase I never
recommended a show so I'm just not
authoritative enough to recommend a shoe
I wear myself make your own choice I've
been born to run two we recommend a shoe
because we can't just be agnostic saying
hey you should pick a shoe but it's up
to you but I never actually tried them
on myself uh I was arguing in favor of a
more minimal shoe so I'm in this running
shoe store and they bring out a pair of
the ultra Escalante racer I put it on
like minus too much shoe rip out the
insole still too much shoe and Eric's
like this is a super stripped down
minimal shoe for everybody else but for
me I always feel like man if it's too
comfortable I'm gonna fall apart my form
is going to go to hell and to me that's
what it's all about if you learn any
other craft if you're learning a martial
art they're not like patting you up and
stuff they are letting you learn how to
move and you uh you match the craft over
time and to me running should be no
different and I can only really feel
like I'm in control of form if I'm
actually feeling what my feet are doing
on the ground yeah are you guys familiar
with Tony riddle you know this guy is
British guy had him on the podcast yeah
um he's he's uh he goes by the natural
lifestylist on on Instagram he's got a
pretty big following and you know he got
rid of the chairs in his house like he
Wilding running yeah I think yeah I mean
I don't know how he's branded it or
whatever yeah maybe he's yeah rewilding
running right um he's done a couple
Adventures he did this thing one man two
feet Three Peaks and made a documentary
about it where he did The Three Peaks
challenge in the UK running on vivos
like on the roads in between the Peaks
but then scaling or yeah and then
scaling the the Peaks which are very
Rocky and rugged like Barry but yeah he
came out here and we went on a run in
Malibu Creek State Park and he went
Barefoot and there's like there's so
many loose little you know I I put on
vibrums just in good spirit and I'm not
super experienced with that and that was
a lot for me and I I could not believe
how
um balletic like how graceful he was
running over like very rough I mean he's
been doing it for a long time I have a
gravel driveway and he could like run on
it and do drills on it I can't walk on
it Barefoot without it hurting my feet
yeah clearly you know there's something
profound going on here
um but I think for me and I probably am
a stand-in for the audience like there's
an aspiration to be
more like that
um but it does require like a long-term
commitment to get there let's look at it
yeah let's look at a different way um
your feet are sources of sensual
pleasure you know one reason why we like
running shoes one reason why we like the
hokas is they feel good the reason why
we have more than one pair of running
shoes is we like that sensual pleasure
of trying something new on our feet same
reason why we like to vary our meals
well this tasted great for breakfast I
want something different for lunch and
that's why yeah I was in a place and
actually that same Ultra Running Company
hey try these shoes oh these feel
fantastic can I have them I don't need
them but I like them and so there is
that sensual Joy of comforting your feet
with something
to me rather than say well you have to
commit to learning form what if you
decide I'm going to really relish the
sensual pleasure of freeing up my feet
I've actually experimented on that
gravel driveway because over time it's
going to feel really good you don't have
to make it punishment you don't have to
say okay I'm gonna walk up and down this
gravel driveway like it's a bit of hot
coals I'm going to try a little bit I'm
going to sense it and see what it feels
like my wife who was not a runner she
was a dancer and she got sort of
dragooned into this whole thing when we
started to run with our rescue donkeys
but her genius technique was to learn
barefoot running she would just set out
Barefoot on an asphalt road with her
shoes in her hand and the second it was
at all uncomfortable she put her shoes
on and then finished the run but over
time she went from 50 feet to a thousand
feet to a mile and that was it as soon
as it's no longer pleasurable switch it
up and what is the what is your sense of
like how long making that full
transition takes to do it responsibly
see I I I think that's the wrong way to
approach it that this is sub should be
something that's different for everybody
and seen as a tool and a training tool
and I I don't think
for me using my athletes as an example
you know I just had someone finish 100
Miler and we we have him in minimal
shoes some of the time we have him doing
foot core exercises we have him doing a
lot of different types of training but
then he's picking the job or the tool
for the job for the race right and so I
don't think it has to be this this
either or and I think that's where
people start to see it's it's I'm either
a minimal Runner or I'm not see see this
as a tool and in training just like you
do your your intervals and your your
threshold runs and and that is because
it is trained in every step can be a
form of strength training yeah well this
book has come at a really opportune
moment for me because I've been
suffering from some pretty chronic lower
back issues and sciatic pain I've got
some numbness in my foot and you know
that's very concerning and has benched
me from running and sent me on a bit of
a world tour of you know meeting with
you know all manner of Specialists all
of whom seem to have you know versions
of the same advice but also very
different at times which can be
paralyzing and confusing but one thing
has become abundantly clear which is the
lack of uh my my brain to connect with
certain muscle groups so it's not even
that they're weak like they don't don't
work my brain says move that muscle and
nothing moves right my glutes don't fire
Etc I've got tight hips and all these
sorts of you know knots that I'm trying
to untangle with a lot of the you know
the drills and some of the advice that
that you give in the book and I watch
some of your videos as well
um it's been slow going for me and so I
am going to make this about me and say
yeah maybe you can like you know we can
go out there afterwards or really you
can like look at me a little bit I'm not
gonna let you leave without taking
advantage of that opportunity
yeah all right cool
um
so you know using me as a proxy for the
typical middle-aged person who kind of
maybe had a history of running but has
banged up a little bit and you know I
like I'm reading this and I'm feeling a
sense of hope like I really want to be
able to run pain-free fall in love with
this thing that I care so deeply about
and it's been really you know
frustrating to not be able to move my
body the way that I would like to yeah
and I think you said one thing that
really resonate resonates with my
experience in my cans clinics coaches
people I hear from
um that the neuromuscular strength
component where you're lacking that
activity from a neuromuscular standpoint
and I think that's a really big key
where
people and athletes Focus so much on
developing strength and getting stronger
and core exercises are great example you
may have the strongest core in in the
world but unless you're using it in a
functional manner
it doesn't matter and so having that
neuromuscular connection is the type of
strength I see most Runners needing and
lacking the most and you know just as a
general statement a lot of that starts
at the feet you can't train the glute
activity properly unless you engage the
feet and I think that's that would be
the first thing we would we would look
at have you had success working with
because you there's a section in there
where you go through kind of common
ailments that people have I didn't see
one for lower back pain but I'm I'm sure
you've had to contend with that with it
yeah I I you know again just general
observation with what you're saying is
that my sense is that the back pain is
just a symptom is that more times than
not where you're feeling it is just a
symptom of of another culprit and that's
what I would explore is like okay
let's maybe not look to treat the back
is there something else that we can look
at maybe hip flexors so as you know I'm
sure you've heard all that but um so I I
that's that would be my Approach is that
okay if the back if it's truly not a
back injury
what what's maybe causing the back to
let you know something's going on and we
look in that direction yeah I mean
that's 100 what it is because I I have
you know I have a little bit of sponty
but it's not like I have a slipped disc
or there isn't I've had an MRI like
there's nothing to create like it's not
perfect but it's not like oh man you
need surgery so I know that it doesn't
necessarily just live in that local spot
that it's a it's a manifestation of a
you know yeah my my sense with the whole
sciatic maybe we look at tfl
kind of what's going on inside of the
hip yeah the hips the hips start to hurt
the top of the hamstring start to hurt
then my my feet will will hurt like and
I'm like this is not right so it
literally travels right down the chain
you feel like one place then another
then another yeah I mean yeah I mean
those are kind of where I feel it yeah
like if like I could go out and run now
fine but like
um after a certain number of miles I'll
feel it in my hips and then I'll just be
a little bit more sore than I should be
the next day and my feet will hurt when
I put weight on them and I'm like that's
not right that was exactly the idea of
this book so when we started to talk
about it
the idea was was well
we want a universal book we wanted this
to be literally the ultimate training
guide but where is the cross-section
between veteran Runners and beginners or
people in the middle and what we came up
with and this was a shock to us we did a
photo shoot in Colton California and
Lewis had gathered this great wonderful
diverse group of people for photos and
we were just running them through some
skills just for the photographic
purposes and then Eric was pointing
stuff out like oh my God I'm shocked at
what I'm seeing Jenna Crawford who won
the Rose Bowl half marathon
fantastically uh trained Runner but
watching her glutes shake like a paint
mixer and Eric's I see her glutes
they're switching on they were dormant
switching on now and we realized even
people who are at Peak Fitness have
these what we call wobbles little wobble
yeah in your mechanism they could then
and it sounds like exactly what's
happening with you rich as you're in a
run and that little wobble is taking its
Tolls by mile five is catching up so we
wanted a book where we could tell people
you can go back to a factory reset you
can go back to First principles rewire
yourself so even if you're a beginner or
you're a veteran you can both arrive at
the same place of feeling like you're
running is really dialed in
one of the really counter-intuitive and
fascinating aspects of of
you know getting started on this
adventure was this idea of of
starting with going fast right you just
think like well you start slow and you
build up your Fitness and then you get
faster but the best way to evaluate
where you are and what you need to work
on is to get somebody to Sprint first or
run you know run really hard because you
can't hide from your form in that regard
and then you kind of build into your
slower form from what you learn about
what You observe when somebody's running
very quickly yeah with that specifically
you know I like to change
The Athlete's perspective of how they
gain speed there's two ways to gain
speed Cadence or frequency of how often
we strike the ground and secondly our
distance prescribed and when you put
someone in a sprinting
um
environment
I can then see are they do they reach
for their speed through the leg reaching
out in front of them or over striving
over stride yeah versus switching their
mindset to the other leg and and pushing
into the ground to propel themselves
forward
and changing their mindset so for me
it's it's seeing seeing what they do in
a speed environment and then using that
that information to kind of go from
there right and and ideally it should it
should always settle around
180 right that that's that's the magic
goal right you know so talk a little bit
about why that is and what that means
yeah so I mean
coaches Through Time have analyzed Elite
athletes Elite Runners and kind of
that's been come the magical number that
those Elite athletes tend to have that I
think that's where that number came from
so I see it as an aspirational number
for a lot of people
um use Chris as an example you know with
his with his height he's maybe always
going to gravitate to utilizing his
distance prescribed just a little bit
more than I would or I might
um kind of focus on the Cadence a little
bit more but for me and my athletes and
and people that I want to kind of effect
is that that 180 number is just
something that we look to get better and
better at
180 steps a minute exactly 90 each leg
and to me the the light bulb Rich was
when Eric was explaining this to me and
he put in terms of you watch a box a
boxer Skip and rope I'm going to leave
the mic now for a second but not doing
this right
we're doing this yeah right
and light on their feet bouncing and
they're using all that elastic recoil
they're turning their bodies into a
gigantic spring and when Eric explained
this 180 in that context like I get it
you're not using muscular Force to LEAP
stop leap stop you're using elastic
recoil spring strength Just Bounce
Bounce Bounce and you can translate that
into running and in terms of figuring
out the optimal way to translate that
there's this idea of of beginning with
your back like pretty close up against
the wall and jogging in place
essentially right which is training you
to really lift your knee and not get
into that over striding kind of you know
traditional way that we that most of us
run when we're you know just doing it
the way that we feel like we should be
doing it right and and
what we wanted to do is and I've said
this is
run form is not difficult
learning it takes five minutes you just
described it running in place against a
wall you'd understand where you strike
the ground now you put a little bit of
music to it at 180 beats per minute
you have your Cadence okay you can't
kick back so you can't over stride that
gives you the sense of how your
relationship with the ground works as a
runner and so then where the challenging
part comes in is then having to develop
that muscle memory right for it to take
hold and that's the piece that maybe
people don't understand is that I see a
lot of people
they think they've learned to run
with good form and then when that muscle
memory starts to create some frustration
they think they need to learn more
and it continues that frustration where
it's maybe throwing in some skills and
drills and and and part of that that
neuromuscular strength that is really
what needs to take place like the human
the humans just hardwired to try to over
complicate it right exactly where do I
go behind the VIP rope there's got to be
more than just this like running place
you know with my back to the wall thing
right it was funny Rich we were with an
athlete yesterday in Phoenix so super
skill very strong athlete and a dancer
and it was great watching Eric in action
because she's a non-run doesn't like it
has been conditioned to hate it and she
would ask her a question and he would
say okay try this and he gave her these
different skills to do and I watched in
real time in five minutes how she
progressed from a very awkward pointing
her foot
um kicking back everything wrong and
then in five minutes suddenly she and
Eric are going side by side she's
relaxing loose and we stopped for a
minute and Eric started to work with her
husband and we started to run back I had
to call Eric over like dude she's doing
it again and I was watching her it's
like she was processing everything that
she thought she'd heard and was trying
to then do it instead of just feeling it
she was thinking it and everything went
to hell again wow that's amazing yeah um
and the The Rock Lobster song The B-52
song playing that there's a purpose to
that which is that the beat mimics the
180 you know sort of Strokes per minute
that you're looking for so there's this
whole whole section of the book that's
fascinating about music should you
listen to music when you're running
should you not listen to it should you
find music that that has the beat you
know that's that's going to train that
neurochemistry to you know develop that
type of cadence and I love that this
conversation transpires between you know
Eminem flea and like Rick Rubin like
none of which are people you think about
when you think about running yeah our
friend lady Southpaw yeah right and my
long postponed conversation with Rick
Rubin which was supposed to have
happened here when I got dragged away to
look for uh Micah it finally took place
10 years later so yeah so talk about
that a little bit I think just that
story is great
um so the wrong option thing in
particular so Eric and I are having this
conversation and Eric can really become
sort of quantum physically about stuff
we're looking at the uh the fitness
chapter and he sent me over like 30
exercises and I said dude I will speak
on behalf of the American public we are
not doing 30th no you need to tell a
story yeah that's true but also I got
limited attention span give me three
exercises you gotta hope you give me 30.
it's a it's a non-starter and with Rock
Lobster when we're discussing 180 per
minute or you have to carry a metronome
how are we going to do this and we had
this conversation like well music has a
rhythm walls right there and we can
really simplify it and then once Rock
Lobster's in your brain you cannot like
pressure wash it out it's there for life
so once you learn to run to that beat
you got it
um and then for the whole music
questions the same thing I'm like
we're having this conversation back and
forth like we're purists we do not wear
our earbuds we want to have our thoughts
but I'm like you know what I've never
actually been in a race when someone
starts playing Gloria Gaynor that I
don't run better you know as soon as the
music's on I'm like ready to go I've
never had a run that was worse with
music so how are we going to sort of
navigate this and that's when we just
kind of put out the uh the bat signal
like get some opinions about this and
you know so fleas on the record adamant
no music
and then we reach out to this woman lady
Southpaw who's a punk musician who has
done an entire album of songs punk songs
specifically to accompany her on her own
New York City marathon and she wrote all
these songs and she plays them and then
uh so we have this back and forth you
know she's like Pro Music flea's like no
music we reach out to Rick Rubin who in
all things of course is the Grand Master
group the voodoo yeah Buddha stepped in
and sort of enlightened us and the way
to go I loved I loved his his
um his salamic wisdom on this one yeah
what did he say he said uh when uh his
he's like the question you need to ask
is when do you want to be at the mercy
of music right like you can understand
that flea like flee is music so when he
goes running he needs a break from that
right but not everybody is a musician so
they can leverage it for certain
purposes I mean I think there's Beauty
in both but I do like this idea of
programming a playlist of songs that all
have that
specific beat when you're in the process
of trying to you know rewire your brain
and your and your form and your
Technique around that Cadence and with
it I think what's key is to to feel the
Cadence to feel the music to Feel The
Beat versus looking at the watch we can
you know we can have our watch tell us
where we're at but that doesn't create
that feeling and understanding of what
it feels like it's just like feeling a
good and bad stroke you feel a bad one
and you adjust while you're swimming I
want people to while they're running to
feel good and bad so they can adjust
this is really the common idea of the
entire book is that understand the
purpose of what you're doing so we look
at like food for instance our first
chapter your fork is not your coach so
many people get into running as a
relationship with their food they're
either trying to lose weight or get in
shape and if you're on that hamster
wheel you will never be happy you will
never outrun a bad diet and so you know
we're not going to be purists but you
know film off a tone has a thing called
the two-week test which to me is like
the genius approach to food don't say I
should be keto I should be vegan listen
let's just strip out all the high
glycemic foods for two weeks reboot your
system reintroduce them see how you feel
minimalist Footwear let's take your
shoes off see how you feel if you want
to put on a cushion shoe have at it
right but
if you want to understand the
relationship between what you're using
and what results you want to have you
need to get back to First principles
music is the same way rather than just
blasting something in your head to
forget to distract yourself maybe
there's a purpose if you put on like
lady Southpaw genius did put on 180
beats per minute she's getting the
satisfaction of an uplifting uplifting
Melody but at the same time she's got
180 strides and it's a tool that
actually helps her as opposed to
distancing herself from The Experience
yeah
um
you mentioned uh Phil mafatone the
mafitone method I mean I I Love Phil
maffetone's teachings it was
transformational in my own you know
endurance Journey did Rick Rubin tell
you that Phil mafton used to live with
him he like moved him in with him
what's funny is that's a weird
Confluence of like two worlds that you
would not predict anything in the world
of Phil mophatone is is cool and weird
uh he lives in a place called Oracle
Arizona and of course you do film office
where else would you live it's a place
called Oracle I met with him once here
in California he said hey let's go over
and check out like Shangri-La like you
mean like the place where Dylan hung out
he's like oh yeah I got the key he's
like what oh yeah you know I'm buddies
with Rick Rubin and he brought me in to
deal with Johnny Cash I'm like dude
every time you open your mouth right
it's a journey nuts yeah you think he's
a runner's geek kind of guy like what is
he doing you know meeting Rick and
dealing with Johnny Cash right it's wild
why are you even in this world and why
is Mike Pig calling you in the first
place you know you're a chiropractor
from Buffalo yeah but that's it that is
the weird journey of film offatone well
he's really initiated this conversation
that that seems to be mushroom clouding
at least on the internet right now
around Zone training like in my world
the there's so much interest in zone 2
training and understanding what it means
to you know be in that aerobic State and
their super geeky podcasts and we
certainly had many conversations here
about that your whole section in this
book which is under the focus uh pillar
is really about Zone training and it
could have been an incredibly dry like
here's you know a scientific with graphs
and all kinds of stuff about like how
you set your zones and why these zones
are important and how to train at the
polarities of them instead it's about
Caesar's Roman army Runners and you know
Laird talking about you know how to hold
your breath and why that's so important
so that's just such a beautiful way to
introduce what could be you know
difficult topics for people to
understand in a way that allows them to
kind of resonate in your memory
for me I'm not really interested in
something that's a new revelation or a
gadget I get really curious when I start
to see the same thing popping up again
and again again throughout history if
you look at taramada wadachis those
sandals like wow you know what Romans
Centurion is warm read Messengers wore
them the taramada could wear different
Footwear they have the capability to put
arch supports or cushions into those
sandals they chose not to so to me it
makes sense when you have a timeline of
a device that has re-emerged cold
plunges okay they've been doing it
throughout history for a particular
reason
and zoned training the zone two training
if you look at the physiology anytime we
start to put ourselves into a state of
oxygen distress the second we are out of
that zone two and we're starting to
approach our aerobic threshold then
your body has a physiological change you
know your peripheral vision will kind of
shrink down your body posture will
change you are in this you're in a
flight mode and your body reacts to that
and so to me joy quotient starts to go
down a little bit completely and
actually what your body is going to then
where it's going to a stored memory is
going to be hey never put yourself in
this position again because this is
trouble
and so when you start to do zone two
training and you realize oh there's a
way where my back's open my diaphragm is
expanded I'm actually enjoying what I
see I'm smelling and sensing things
because just because of pure body
chemistry when your body is in distress
mode you're going to shut out sensory
perception only in tunnel vision
and then you start to look back through
time like huh let's look at the Romans
Insurance what was their Pace because
what they were famous for was they were
covering a ton of distance with packs in
a record amount of time that's what made
them so formidable and you start to look
out and people have done this you know
the military historian like uber
scientists had figured out strides per
minute and miles per hour and what you
see is they're basically locking in its
own too right so 2 000 years ago they
understood Zone training and they had
these basically these three phases right
like it was the yeah with the rocks and
like with the heavy equipment how far
can they go in a single day and they
would set it at like what was it it was
something like you know 20 miles in five
hours or something like that and they
had different they had different
distances and periods of time that were
really basically setting their zones
right right and then mandating them the
same way author Lydia did and the way
drill sergeants do today they do it by
calling own response which again I found
faster which is just a different version
of rock lobster right right yeah like
you can sing a song so it's singing a
song in your aerobic Zone calling
response is like the Zone would be zone
three right right right yeah and uh and
then you know obviously you're not doing
anything when you're going all out yeah
and so when you're looking at author
Lydia when he basically began modern
jogging he was working with cardiac
patients in Auckland and he had a
mandate conversational Pace do not run
any faster than you can maintain a
conversation he mandated his own two but
he didn't say hey set your watches and
it's like if you can chat with your
buddy you're in the right Zone mafadone
does something similar and then I think
um what you see today is in military
training and boot camp they want
everybody in they don't want somebody in
the distress mode they want them to be
able to go all night for an
unpredictable distance and so they do
first they do chance and then when you
click over to another Zone you go call
in response where you only have to have
half of the conversation right and it's
understanding that in those moments if
you're in Caesar's Army you're going to
be called upon to suddenly Sprint but
when you arrive at you know what you're
sprinting towards you have to fight
right so you can't be buckled over right
so it's like do you have the fitness to
be able to do that and do you have the
the conscious awareness to pace yourself
to go as fast as you need to go to get
there but also be able to handle your
sword when you arrive right so you know
when Joe v hill first saw the Taro MATA
in Leadville and this is something I I
it took me years to unpack and it's the
reason why I got Born to Run two didn't
happen a couple years after born and
runs I still did not really understand
what I was seeing
and Joe vigil told a story you know he
is America's preeminent uh cross-country
coach has worked with Olympic athletes
and he talked about the fact that I've
seen it all but what I've never seen his
Smiles these guys are mile 60s
scrambling up a hill and they're having
a good time he told me that story
I related it it was interesting to me I
didn't get it until years later and V
Hill's point is these guys have got
their their gears figured out they're a
mile 60 it's 100 mile race they're up a
hill and they can't dial it back then
they're they're toast and they've
learned how to instinctly dial it back
I'm like okay if I'm in a point now or
I'm having fun slipping up the hill I'm
in the right Zone he saw it and got it
and it took me years to understand what
he saw
did you see that uh the other day
killing Journey like published all his
training data I did see so the endurance
endurance Twitter is losing their mind
right like everyone's like geeking out
on like going deep into all his data uh
there's been some articles written about
it
um but what I thought was really
fascinating and instructive about that
is over the course of something like
1200 hours of of training over the
course of the year
um
there were two really important things
that jumped out and I'm interested in
what you think about this the first was
how much of it was at lower intensity 88
was at Zone one or zone two like Zone
one 56.9 zone 2 20.2 zone five like his
all-out effort only 3.8 percent of his
training which goes to show you like
he's in that like let's have a laugh and
sing a song
the majority of the time when he's out
there of those 1200 hours the second
thing was
um he's starting to question the
validity of these long runs like he he
kind of even tweeted the other day like
I don't know if we need to be like it's
more about frequency and he was
comparing that approach to what Camille
Herron is doing and the success that
she's having like she'll do two or three
runs in a day but she won't go out and
do that super long you know Saturday or
Sunday run that the rest of us are doing
Lots there yeah yeah
um I I I'm glad you're bringing this up
because uh now I get the cookie yeah
this is Let's Go Geek yeah um so I think
Killian one thing you know he's fasted
pretty much every distance yeah and if
if we look at his everything you just
mentioned
I think what listeners need to hear
there is that
he is fast enough
to be able to go easy enough
on that 88 right his Zone one is
probably like a seven minute pace right
right which you know is our walking pace
or whatever like exactly right and so
what you know since the the popularity
of ultra running is the the development
I see most needed with most athletes is
that they need to get faster first so
they are able to run easy enough to even
make cutoffs or to be able to run in
zone two Zone one for a very long time
lots of athletes especially in in
Mountain environments
don't have the the ability that can be
developed to be able to do what Killian
does but then they go try it
and now they're out for their five hour
run because Killian does but it's you
know
50 60 of it's in zone four and five you
know so taking a step back and
really developing your ability your raw
ability to get faster and then applying
it to what Killian's talking about I
think is really really what's missing
for a lot of athletes yeah that's
interesting I mean that's the reverse of
kind of how I've always thought about it
and practiced it yep like my whole thing
was build from the build from the ground
up and create that massive endurance
base and you know occasionally do some
threshold work for Speed because I'm not
trying to run fast anyway I do you know
I know that gear needs a little bit of
attention but it's really not something
I need to rely upon for I think there's
a micro and macro way to look at that is
that back when I was doing Iron Man
there was only two Iron Mans to do is
Hawaii or Canada and so to qualify you
kind of went through the ranks you
started with your Sprint your Olympic
worked your way up to a half and so
there was a development system built in
place just because we didn't have the
ability just to go sign up for an Iron
Man well it's still the case I mean the
people that are killing it at Iron Man
are people that you know went you know
were on that trajectory right because
you can go from really fast to really
long you can't go from really long to
really fast right right and look at just
the development process for runners is
that you know middle school high school
it's you know 3K 5Ks and then you go to
college and it's a little bit more and
it's a little bit more and all of a
sudden now they get to their 30s and
they're ready for the marathon whereas
now the majority of age group athletes
are just jumping into the longer runs or
the longer races which is fine my point
is that they need to understand that
that speed development must really take
place to really escalate their their
ability rather than just doing more yeah
that's super interesting start with the
fast stuff get faster improve your raw
ability and then apply that to go in
longer now that longer efforts faster
and your have you have that ability you
can't run a three-hour Marathon if
you're you know for mile pace is an X
right you know it's a famous Emil's
Adipex story when he trained for his
first marathon he trained by doing 100
meter Sprints people like Emil it's a 26
mile race he goes yeah I thought the
point was to run fast I already know how
to run slow yeah well this is sort of
jumping ahead to the to the kind of
Community Family Fun section of the book
but the story around
um
uh what's his name Billy and his wife
Billy Barnett yeah Billy Barnett and his
wife
after having a baby and going from just
you know endurance lunatics to doing
very little and then having PR's when
they kind of just had let go of any
expectations of even attempting to try
to do anything all that fast
yeah we know I keep harkening back to
the Eternal wisdom of barefoot Ted so
one year I was patient head at Leadville
I pick him up at mile 85. and this is no
man's land and this is the Valley of the
lost the mile 85 in Leadville you know
the 8 station 10 is full of people who
are ready to dnf and tap out it's after
two hope passes right yes and it's dark
it's like two or three o'clock in the
morning when you're coming in take them
through the tent like it's a surprise
party just for Ted happy chatting I'm on
one side tennis on the other I watched
him just like socialize his way through
the tent before he reaches me and he's
like let's go I'm like dude what is up
with you he does a sub 24 Leadville
which is very fast in his own homemade
sandals and he's run about this one guy
we're passing on the trail and some guy
recognize he's like hey Mike I took this
race and I turned it into a chat Fest
the guy's like I'm not surprised he
sounds so much like him right and we're
blah blah blah blah sub 24 I'm like dude
your training had to be massive he's
like I'm doing 25 miles a week I'm like
how in the hell are you doing a sub 24
Leadville on five miles a day with two
days off and he goes mikoso I'm not
interested in the limits of what's
painful I'm interested in the limits of
what's pleasurable and I'm just rolling
my eyes back so hard so far in my head
I'm sprained in my eyeballs but I think
about it he's five miles a day I bet
we're smoking fast he probably did some
yoga you know hiding acai Bowl wherever
how he eats and then just blazed out
he's doing 25 very fast very technical
miles a week and he was able to link
that in Matt Carpenter told me that one
time too the guy who holds the Leadville
record I went to the to the Temple of
Matt Carpenter to learn the secret of
running the world's fastest Leadville
and he took me out to a park with his
like five-year-old daughter and he goes
all right walk to that tree and race
back so I erased the five-year-old I
will not tell you who won and then he
goes all right do it again all right do
it again and that was it walk to the
tree Sprint walk he goes she just gotta
shorten the distances that you're
walking and that's your that's your turn
training wow
to be fair with Barefoot Ted though he's
sitting on years and years of like miles
right so he has this vast reservoir of
endurance capacity
yes there's a lot going on with Ted I
see a picture of Ted today I'm like how
is this guy so freaking jacked you know
like I don't get it he is like three
percent body fat I don't know I cannot
Plumb The Genius of barefoot Ted but I
think he has a lot of things I think he
like me we have a kind of kinship
because I think we're both like
undiagnosed ADHD I think his wheels are
churning from the second his eyeballs
will open in the morning right right
one of the things that that that blew my
mind in this in the book is this uh
connection between the brain and and the
Barefoot
um and this study that showed that
working memory improved 16 after a
Barefoot run whereas there's no
improvements with normal shoes like this
is insane like the fact that like by
going out and having your feet be in
contact with nature while you're running
um that that that like Highway between
what's going on up here between the
years and the proprioception like the
Strategic intentional you know mindset
that you have to have about where you're
placing your feed and all of that that
actually has this benefit on your
cognition
yeah I mean
that to me says it all I mean it in in
where it can is
we all can do this
in the way that we need to for our own
selves it's that
you might just start running on the the
dirt road or the gravel that you talked
about and someone else might be doing it
all the time like Chris but it all has a
benefit in our own way in finding it
doesn't have to be that All or Nothing
thing that maybe what's what's out there
is that you don't have to just become a
minimal Runner it's like use it as a
tool and this is coming from a coach is
that it's so powerful it's how we use
our feet is such an element of what
athletes need to do
and it just you know it was my aha
moment as a coach and it just so so
potent and
um take it from there Chris yeah well so
you mentioned Billy Barnett the fact
that this guy age 36 with a nine month
old baby had minimal training because he
was the primary caregiver in the
afternoon his wife's working all day
when Billy came home from teaching
school he would be responsible for Cosmo
and if Cosmo wasn't up for it then they
weren't running that day nine months of
this he walks out and he podiums the
Honolulu Marathon right he's like he was
just doing it on a flyer he literally
only signed up because he realized oh it
sounds like there aren't that many
people running this year so I can just
get jump into last minute and the last
minute jump in he ends up blazing out a
PR as fast as Marathon 225 or something
like that yeah yeah third place overall
finish and then what's her name Alex
Alex Alex and then she like crushes the
hurt 100 to hurt 100 has her best ever
hurt 100 and she struggled with that
race but to me that's what it's all
about this idea of the sensual pleasure
you know we had these two chapters in
the book about family and fun it's a
very antithetical note to have in a
training book but it really gets back to
physiological Roots things that you
enjoy you will be predisposed to repeat
them and want to do them things where
you're in a group I mean we think about
in evolutionary terms you would never
run off into the Wilderness by yourself
you would never come back we evolved to
run as hunting packs in concert with
other people and you feel it you've
never had a run with a buddy that felt
bad you never came back like wow that
was a bad idea the bigger the group The
more fun it is unfortunately we have
turned running into this thing well if
it feels good we're probably doing it
wrong you know it should feel bad we
should be by ourselves we should be
racing our Strava and what we're finding
again and again is if we actually
embrace those tadamata evolutionary
roots family and fun and incorporate
into our workouts the results are
amazing sure and you're also creating
sustainability for this thing that you
enjoy doing I think it is
you know it's it's part of just our
whole Western mindset right like if I'm
going out for a run like I've got this
much time I gotta extract the maximum
amount of Fitness out of this
opportunity so I'm going to go run as
fast as I can for you know how long I
you know for that distance that I can
maintain and unless I you know butt up
against that pain point then it was a
waste of time right we've we've
unfortunately associate fun with with
Badness you know you know if I eat a
quart of haagen-dazsa that's fun I'm
enjoying this and it's not so good for
me but and that's what I want to do
really accomplish with the gears getting
back to the zones and the gears that I
wanted people to really see and make
that correlation from okay if I'm if I
want to run x amount for Pace mile
what does that correlate to as far as a
time interval so they're training and
not straining and keeping it we're
talking about fun right now but it's
it's that Str you know going from not
straining to training to accomplish what
you're looking to accomplish to give
them a correlation between time and
speed yeah and you have this set of
tables in the back of the book it's it's
in every man's way of establishing what
those zones are without having to do a
proper lactate test you go out you run a
mile and based upon that you can kind of
establish how to go about that right and
again understanding what is an
appropriate level of effort for what
you're trying to achieve that day so if
they if an athlete knows hey I'm going
to the track to do
um two two minute repeats I know what my
speed should be to accomplish that
versus going out too hard so and and and
it really a lot of it is about the
polarities right you want to be doing
your Zone one in your zone two and then
you choose your moments for your zone
five and mean the way I've kind of been
going about it is most of it is in that
lower Zone stuff and running the trails
around here but then I'll go to the
track and that's where I'll take my
shoes off on grass or even on you know a
kind of a padded track and do a lot of
drills and you know try to develop that
that foot connection and the foot
strength right absolutely one thing Eric
would do with me early on this isn't
that first honeymoon period where he's
training me
uh the first thing he did one time was
he
sent me a workout for a two hour run
I mean just dude there's no way you know
I can barely run three miles two hours
but what you find is when you have the
mind saying oh man I'm gonna be out here
for two hours no matter what I loaded up
a backpack like I was like it's like
trying to summon the Himalayas you know
I brought toilet paper with me I thought
what do you do if you're out there for
two hours I've never done anything like
this
so I set off on this two-hour journey
into the unknown and what you realize
after an hour like you better just
simmer down and take it easy otherwise
you're not going to finish but you relax
into it and that's when the sense of fun
and joy came into it and then for longer
runs again we were training for the 50
mile and a Copper Canyon on a long run
he would have me do hill repeats in the
middle again I thought this was like
stupid you're taxing me out you're
burning me out in the middle of a run
but it taught me to wake up get my form
dialed in got my heart rate up again
instead of this is still a slow steady
slot toward the finish line so his way
of incorporating those gear changes you
know we kind of rev the engine a little
bit where it's just to me just brilliant
yeah I mean that's where you get into
real Fitness right and Iron Man it's all
about like the slow locomotive you kind
of get up to speed and then you just
hold it there all day but you don't have
that you don't have a lot of gear change
ability you know in that distance if
you're training for that specifically
and when you are doing those gear
changes you create that resilience so
you can attack a hill but you're also
because you're doing so much aerobic
work you can bring that heart rate back
down quickly so you don't have to stop
at the top of the hill and buckle you
know Buckle over for a minute but for me
even more so it's it's what we're doing
for the structural system is that a lot
of what's in the book waking up all
those muscles and groupings and using
them in an appropriate manner activating
things we we were in Lawrence Kansas
what two days ago or whatever it was and
you know kind of our Mo for these events
have been start out with some of our our
skills in the book
and then go for a run and we did some
neuromuscular jumping and and
um what we call leg stiffness leg
stiffness is a crucial element for
performance and Longevity for good
health and running and so we went
through our leg stiffness exercises and
then went for a trail run and after the
trail run two two gals came up to me and
they they said those exercises were
transformed my running in a matter of 30
minutes because normally I would not be
able to run that trail as a steady run I
felt like I could run forever and that's
that's the connection that you're
talking about and that how
faster running for me is less about
maybe the anaerobic or what we consider
it from a cardiovascular standpoint but
what it's doing with our connection with
the ground and our structural system we
were in Baltimore with a group called
The Riot Squad running as our therapy
and there's a new Runner there Justine
and toward the end of the run it's
getting dark she's laboring struggling
and we had done Rock Lobster exercise
beforehand and she kind of looks over
it's like what was that song again you
know rock lobster she gets on her phone
punches it up and like that her running
switch because she's the point where now
she's just slogging it she put the song
on all of a sudden she started a
pitter-patter and then brought the run
in for a landing but she did it out of
sense of desperation like everything
else sucks maybe the song will help and
it really did um what does that mean leg
stiffness
essentially your ability to land and get
off the ground as quickly as possible
helping your Cadence so I I see Cadence
and leg stiffness go hand in hand for
performance and for longevity or you
know that that real feel-good we want
out of running where it takes away
tightness when we hear leg stiffness
that's a good thing it doesn't mean lack
of Mobility or tightness it's it's your
ability to use and operate the springs
and rubber bands in your body to land
and snap and get off of it as quick as
possible I see yeah cool so
um what's the most common thing that you
come across like you're me you're doing
all these things with all these running
groups right you're seeing all shapes
and sizes of Runners uh what is what is
like the refrain you know what's the
thing that people share with you the
most or
um
or you know what is a common
misconception about people's
relationship to running that you'd like
to disabuse people of
wow that's
let me think you keep going because you
always can I'm not a real Runner
invariably there's never been an event
where people don't say I'm not a real
Runner I'm not good at this I'm not as
fast as you believe me you're as fast as
me for starters yeah that doubt lack of
self-confidence and also lack of a sense
that this is an art that you can master
and that's to me is it and it it's
always like a
a real Pleasant shock to them when we
start to do these skills and they
realize oh okay I get I can do this
yesterday we're working this athlete in
Arizona and she's a dancer so she's
struggling to run and Eric stops and
goes hey show us a couple dance steps
and she's clicked and he's like she just
started to bust out this dance instantly
no hesitation and Eric's like you're a
runner like that's it because her
dancing was this nice rhythmic bouncy
things like just move it forward and
you're a runner I would imagine some of
those people who say I'm not a rail
runner are the people who are out
pushing strollers with their little ones
right and actually you have this thing
in the book about like this is actually
a tool like to improve your running form
we were just with one of uh Eric's
clients Ellen Ortiz
uh in Birmingham she's fantastic but
what I love about her is that she is
Alpha Dog I'm gonna BQ or die kind of
Runner but at the same time when she had
her baby she decided okay now I'm gonna
get really good at this and we're just
like watching like drinking in tips and
information and where she positions the
dog stroller but yeah she's turned this
in an amazing learning tool yeah
talk about a little bit about the
movement snacks I mean that's sort of
drill oriented but I like how you've
encapsulated that and and turned it into
like a fun thing yeah the the movement
snacks are something that you can do
anytime anywhere for a variety of
reasons but how we strategically
use them in the book is a lot of
diving into the Diagnostics of the
injury chapter where
um maybe the the movement snacks are a
strategic way to begin to add more
Mobility or
give you a sense of where you're lacking
in movement while you're then
implementing some of the the remedies
for that specific injury these are these
are developed by a friend of ours Julie
Angel who comes from a parkour
background and so what Julie Julie's
actually a filmmaker who started to film
parkour athletes and as an observer she
realized oh they've got some really kind
of cool
full natural movement skills that a lot
of people could benefit from so she
extracted movement snacks from the
isolated movements of Parkour athletes
like Precision jumping or quadrupedal
movement right controlling around on all
fours yeah yeah but that kind of thing
too to balance on your left foot and
your right hand at the same time and
move forward and then she realized these
are fun they are non-threatening and
that if you do a little bit of bear
crawl for like 30 seconds and you stand
up Everything feels loosened and so I
think it's kind of a genius move by by
Julie to create movement snacks because
you take that group of people I'm not a
runner I don't want to do this I don't
do that oh yeah so the parkour Community
will form a big circle as a way of
saying hello and then they will bear
crawl to the center and everyone will
high five and then they'll reverse and
bear crawl backwards back out that's the
warm-up but they've now extended their
entire chain of motion their arms
shoulders backs are loosened and they're
ready to go out and work out so that's
what we we basically uh adopted all
these things from from Julius and
movement snacks
cool
are you guys still in a formal coaching
athlete relationship
yeah I'm like Curious like what does
Chris still need to work on like what is
like what does that look like I'll cover
my ears like yeah I I assume it's more
than just like here's your workout like
it's not about that it's more about like
technique and form and
strategy no when he mentioned when we
were in Colton California doing the
photo shoot he still had the best form
there
and so he's here that Jenna Crawford
yeah right right best form Ever
um what's most important with what Chris
does is he understands what he wants out
of running
and he sticks to that mission is that
what's most important for him is to do
it properly
and that trumps everything and you know
when when we first started working
together his goal was to be able to run
anywhere anytime any distance and that's
that's kind of where we say you know
begin the book of his his transformation
or 15 years and so
I I there's
I I think
he moving to Calif or to Hawaii
and living there full time now I'm going
to be really interested to see how he
gravitates to the trail systems there
and he's even got me
um interested in getting back into
swimming because he's talking about some
swim run challenges and just kind of
create an adventure so
um it's you know he he's he's inspired
me a lot recently just to kind of maybe
get back into swimming so that's cool
yeah have you done any swim runs oh yeah
I mean on my own I've kind of yeah
invented some like little roots of my
own but I gotta get back to what Eric
says I feel like I'm the
guy that can't Coast you know I didn't
come into it with
um the natural abilities and I came in
from it from a history of hating it and
disdaining it and being hurt
and so that's why for me form is like
foremost on my mind I feel like I barely
got my arms around this and so to me
it's a priority I think stronger better
faster athletes
can get by for a while before they run
into trouble I'm starting from a
position of trouble but I also dig it
because you know it's like if you watch
someone do something even if you don't
know the sport but it's elegant and
clean and Powerful I don't know what a
backhand is supposed to look like but
you watch you know Serena doing oh I
guess that's pretty darn good and for me
that's what running feels like I think
people misunderstand that focusing on
form is tedious to me it's really joyful
because when you get that moment oh that
felt good oh that one felt good too how
many strides can I String but as far as
swim run dude come on out uh I got some
fun roots and I just did on my own
because you realize huh there's a canal
that can swim across about a half a mile
right where I can run a certain Trail
and it pops out on a series of beaches
with rock Jetty in between so you can
come off a trail jump in the water swim
a quarter mile land on the beach run
down swim another quarter mile yeah and
just you know make your own swing yeah I
love it um are you are you on Oahu yeah
yeah are you like in the Honolulu area
or like Kailua like up north yeah cool
yeah that's where my wife grew up yeah
I'm nearby in Kaneohe yeah yeah that's
that's very cool no I I went down the
swim run Rabbit Hole I did otilo in
Sweden and you know it's it's cool in
Europe like it's a whole thing man and
these guys have it dialed and it's a
it's a very specific skill set we went
in me and my coach Chris South we were
we were totally unprepared for you know
what exactly we were getting into but so
fun and I love when the environment
dictates the adventure and the
experience it's not like oh it's an Iron
Man has to be this distance we just lay
this you know Tableau on top of the
terrain it's the other way around and
you know it's all it's all about like
respect like if you drop like a gel pack
on the you're disqualified if anybody
sees you like zero tolerance policy for
that it's really all about like the
Beauty and the immersion in these
beautiful places but I remember like let
me I'll just share this one story like
we in the days leading up to that race
we're in Stockholm and you know a bunch
of the athletes are there because it's
in the archipelago off the coast and and
uh and and so we're doing like just
little fun you know last minute training
sessions literally running like down the
city streets of Stockholm in wetsuits
and like jumping in the water and
swimming across these little waterways
and and there's people you know going to
work and nobody like they're all like oh
yeah that's normal here you know like
the weirdest thing to see like people
running down a city street in a wetsuit
is it an enforced buddy system don't you
have to be with yourself yeah you do it
in in teams of two and you have to stay
within three meters of each other some
some of the teams actually tether
themselves to each other with like a
bungee cord type deal and you can like
use whatever you want like
most people have hand paddles and you
swim in your tennis shoes and the whole
thing and it's crazy I love that partner
aspect of it to me it's yeah that's a
whole new kind of element of the whole
thing which is about
fun and Community Family like all these
things that you talk about in the book
yeah yeah it's cool was it brutally cold
though uh we had the I mean it's a
longer story but yeah we had like the
worst weather ever terrible which made
it epic you know I'm glad in retrospect
I mean it was sideways rain and crazy
wind and chop and swells and all kinds
of stuff did it make it
in retrospect all the more satisfying or
like I really wished it it was terrible
on the day but like yeah now looking
back I'm so glad it wasn't like a glassy
day like we could we you know that's
what we signed up for like I hate cold
water you know I was like I'm gonna go
do this thing that I'm kind of scared of
right
we did fine like we're you know I I held
my coach back of course
as I'm as I should right
um but yeah it was an experience I won't
soon forget and now you're seeing swim
run competitions starting to pop up in
the states and I think that's a really
cool thing yeah and I hope the uh the US
versions actually maintain that um that
buddy mandate to me it's just it's yeah
it's a whole different kind of
experience the Americans yeah they don't
like that though they're like I don't
want to do the thing with I want to just
do it myself right but that's kind of
beside the point yeah that's the whole
thing
um cool well let's let's uh let's end
this with a couple drills things that
you can I don't know if we can like if
it's possible to articulate it in a way
where people can kind of understand but
like one or two things that people could
start to practice where they can get a
gauge on like oh this is why I feel this
way because this thing is weak or what
have you yeah so that maybe we can hit
it from two sides one what we call the
foot core where we can train our feet
we've got muscles on the bottom of our
feet and there's some simple but very
very potent ways to train your feet and
it's just simply you always kind of want
to work Barefoot and simply taking off
your shoes and socks and balancing on
your forefoot on one leg and
Chris is sick of me here and saying this
but you know you're going to feel it
where you need it you're gonna the
weakest link is going to show up it
might be for someone hey they start to
feel it in the feet in the arch or it
might be the calves or hey they're
strong down there they they bike or they
do mountain running and so they're
strong down below the knee but they
start to feel it in their glue and
that's that's how the feet really affect
everything up through the leg so again
simply Barefoot four foot balancing
right I've noticed and I don't know
whether this is an age thing or a
weakness thing or whatever but my
balance got really bad like when I you
know when I stand on one leg or I'm
putting my underwear on or whatever I'm
like
why am I why can't I just you know hold
myself up in a stable way and I think
too in doing these simple
um foot core exercises that you're going
to start to see or feel a difference
between right and left and then you can
start maybe making a correlation of oh
yeah I'm kind of tighter on this side
and and making a correlation of how
poorly or how well you're using each
foot based on how you're feeling as an
athlete The Genius of these exercises
that Eric came up with is I wanted
everything to be something I would
personally do and if I ain't going to do
it I'm not going to put in the book and
things like the one foot balancing if
you're waiting for the coffee to brew
you got two minutes on your hands you
can do this and that's what I really
like about them these are
extraordinarily practical but have a
great residual effect as well and that
doesn't mean they're not potent I mean
right as you're listening right now take
off your shoes and socks and balance on
your forefoot it's it's not an easy
thing and you can see how challenging
and difficult it is and with that
in that position regardless of good or
bad form we're asking ourselves to be in
that position every step as we run and
you need to be stable there and that's
how we can really train the fee it has
these the self-correcting part of this
is that Earth doesn't give you any
instructions on how you he goes just
move your arms and move your legs
however you want to get that balance
what you find is you self-correct you
realize oh if I just kind of tighten my
core up a little bit if I straighten my
posture if I do my arms like this and so
you do it for 30 seconds and your body
will find that balance that you are
struggling for just by putting itself in
that position yeah The Tweak for me is
embracing the fact that so much of that
is about like creating those neural
Pathways it's not about suffering like
you know the athlete in me is like I'm
going to do it until it hurts or how
many of these lifts you know am I gonna
do well I'll just do it until it's
burning like crazy but it's not really
about that it's really about just
developing The Habit as a preset and
that's about like your mind connecting
with that movement it's not about like
you know hitting anything hard it's the
best warm-up you can do because now
we're turning an electrical system on
before we go out and run yeah so another
one leg stiffeners we talked about is
simply there's three types of strength
we have concentric eccentric and
isometric and The Eccentric and
isometric is very rarely talked about
and especially the isometric where it's
that when we land as a runner there's a
moment in time
after our land and before we take off
that is really really crucial for
injuries that isometric hold okay
a lot of Runners don't have that so leg
stiffener exercise would be simply
standing on your right foot barefoot
and just taking a short Leap Forward and
sticking it like a ballerina
without a whole lot of leg movement you
want to stick it without movement and
just kind of progressively hop forward
with that stick two or three five second
stick to create more leg stiffness to
allow you to really get off the ground
right so that that creates the ability
to be resilient in that isometric
position and avoid injury and it's a
great way for people who are training
for a silly race that might not live in
that area and now we're trained in that
eccentric Landing as well that we get
from downhills that maybe they don't
have so yeah cool yeah yeah
um can we go outside yeah and you're
gonna like put me through the ringer
we're gonna look at here all right
what's cool about this is that people
love these exercises people go I'm not a
runner and you have them do the sticky
hop lunges and you just see that like
they're having fun it's a playful game
yeah yeah yeah cool man yeah um well
thanks you guys I appreciate it Born to
Run too I'm so excited for this to be
out in the world again it's the uh it's
the how-to on Born to Run
um I think it's going to help a lot of
people this was a you know a very worthy
investment on your guys's time and like
a gift to all of us
Runners out there in the world so I
appreciate it thanks for having us um
I imagine that there are a lot of people
who are going to come and ask like oh
how you know they're going to want you
to coach them like do you is that what
you do do you is there some place where
people can learn more about you
resources Etc yeah so I I have my
website and ericorton.com and kind of
there's a lot of lots going on I have my
YouTube channel which is kind of the the
place to go see the how-to tips in in
YouTube environment and but what I do
kind of daily is I coach Runners all
over the world for marathon and ultra
running kind of the traditional type of
coaching but then I do camps and Clinics
and speaking and have people visit me in
Jackson Hole to kind of dive into all
all this dysfunction that Runners tend
to have yeah we kind of so kind of
hitting it from two two different
coaching environments yeah very cool and
if there's you know people on the tip of
like community and finding a pack to run
with are there good online resources for
people to go to who are living wherever
who want to see like what's available to
them here in California there's an
amazing one called The Rundown by Iman
Wilkerson and she actually tipped us off
to some of our favorite affinity group
running clubs there's a group in San
Diego called the Santa mujeres Latina
Runners so yeah check out the rundown in
California and points Beyond but
otherwise you just gotta check your
local community there are these we've
been blown away there's run for
Chinatown Harlem run eight six go across
the country there are these incredible
proliferation of small groups yes and
with that one aspect we were kind of
maybe hoping with the book was that
now giving maybe some resources for
people to start their own clubs and
their own Crews and and having maybe a
systematic way about going about it from
from a training perspective yeah yeah
yeah yeah so awesome man well I'll link
up all your socials and websites and all
that kind of stuff and obviously where
to get the book and all that and you
know you guys are probably coming to a
city near the audience at some point
you're kind of on a tour you're going to
go home but you're going to go back out
around the book when this comes out and
I'm sure it's going to be a hit and it's
been lovely talking to you guys I
appreciate it I'm at your service
anything I can do to help you guys out
in the mission this is really fun man
thank you thank you thank you yeah cool
awesome peace yeah that's and thanks for
the Panola right yeah right those bites
are tasty one thing I was gonna ask you
we're still rolling right
um
this is sort of a mic a true thing but
you know when you had to move the market
on chia seeds when Born to Run came out
I'm sure you get asked this all the time
like you could have started a chia seed
company and completely you know
dominated that market it's kind of funny
I was trying to track how many companies
went on Shark Tank based on something
out of Born to Run right and uh my
daughters are having acai bowls and
they're putting Qi on but they hadn't
soaked it you have to soak it they go no
you don't you don't understand I
invented I was a guy
yeah right right there's teenage disdain
for you I don't know dude it was kind of
funny I look back on it and you're not
quite sure like I'm happy to take all
the chips and thing I'm you know the
cause of everything but I don't recall
Chia being around at all until after
born and run came out and then suddenly
bam it was off it went yeah no I don't
remember hearing about it before that
but you know I make damn sure I put
those in my smoothie or on my cereal
pretty much every day yeah do you soak
them first you put them on dry depends
on how how much time I I I sometimes I
don't I know that I'm supposed to and
I'm like yeah I should probably suck
those but like I gotta go you know so
you just uh have him ground up right I
just I like them ground yeah ground and
dry yeah yeah okay yeah to me you gotta
soak them in into those tadpole you know
things but yeah it's kind of a funny
thing and then with Pinole I was getting
blitzed by people saying I want the
thought I'm out of superfood like where
can I get a dude Chihuahua that's your
only answer and then this kid uh Eddie
Eddie Sandoval send them all how do I
keep forgetting his name in Kansas
Wichita Kansas created a company and so
again we're not affiliated at all uh but
I'm just a fan of the fact that he took
the ball on piano and started to run
with it yeah it's very cool all right
man thanks yeah come back again sometime
share some more right on appreciate you
guys
[Music]